we make way for Jalen Rose ESPN NBA
analyst former NBA guard drafted I think
13th overall by the Nuggets back in 1994
J road joins us now do you still play
pick-up I do thank you for having me on
I appreciate the law and lucky number 13
took my family from the city to the
suburbs Thank You Davis parent in the
NBA do you remember what your first
paycheck was I do not I remember my
first contract for six years ten million
dollars I actually came into the league
the final year we're rookies contracts
weren't slotted and my good friend the
big dog actually was one of the guys to
ask for one hundred million dollars
because he was doing number one overall
and to tell you a funny quick story
being in the same draft both feeling
like he was a lottery talent we got to
come out to the combine in Chicago we
both decided we're not going to work out
we don't hang out in Gary Indiana in his
basement and he's rapping and making
beats and doing stuff and I'm just
hanging out kicking it the draft came he
went number one I wore a rare like
suiting with Cochise overall and
watching guys doing front of me I don't
even know who they were
if we had a league and it was the over
50 who would go number one over 50 you
got to always go with side so I'll take
a shat no kid's gonna stop him from
getting dunks down low Ray Allen is
racing on 50 is he he don't get in me
and I'm 40 says okay
Reggie Miller would Reggie can still
play yes so those are those are two
styles so Wayman you can't get Shaq
Shaq's 47 so you oh you got a skill that
a transient and so if you got a body
type usually here's what happen football
players and labor taught when they're
playing they take so many supplements
and stuff when they retire they get
smaller basketball players when they
retire they
you didn't you look like you're about
the same well I have my years then when
I first and tired and I still have some
aches and pain it's tendinitis or that's
all over my body going to the gym and
your body hurt really didn't help a lot
and I have one of those body types and
when I'm not a segment kind of built
like a kangaroo
so I have my kangaroo days and years but
I have to lose it in here right let me
dive into the 76ers topic who is going
to get the blame at the end of the
season with this team
brett brown and you know how
professional sports work you look at the
landscape of their squad you have two
perennial all-stars in Joel embiid and
Ben Simmons and like motional éclairs
their games half-block well Joe well
here is going to be to consistently
bring it on the nightly basis just
because of injury history it's going to
stop if we practice it consistently and
meinen of remaining in tip-top shape and
then finland - for the terrific
all-around games but he doesn't attempt
shot outside of the paint and that's one
of the biggest anomalies we've seen from
a gar that plays that position in a
really long time
you're just in the offseason get Tobias
Harris 180 million on max deal let Jimmy
Butler walking then you bring in Al
Horford and give him a hundred million
so on paper you got four guys making top
dollar and your lower half of it Eastern
Conference usually that falls on the
coach if you could only keep one in
Philadelphia who would you keep if I
only became one this is probably going
to be controversial but I'll take the
healthy player in Ben Turner I love him
beating
I voted him all-nba last season and he's
going to be the same this year along
with yoga chat the center spot but if
you're going for a longevity play on the
best ability of availability and being
is going to be in the practice he's
going to be able to be you know all
season training he's going to be able to
you know show up and play as close to 82
games as possible and then I know what
I'm going to get in the playoffs or
joelle probably won't have an
opportunity of his career to play it in
two games there have been playoff games
it easy
the last couple of years so if there was
a one night I'll take Joelle no doubt
about it because I think he's one of the
top 10 players in the entire league but
I'm talking about the next 10 years
I gotta go longevity will be he's Jalen
Rose Jalen will appear on NBA countdown
tonight then on the jump tomorrow in
Boston before the Rockets Celtics game
on ABC
you can also see him on NBA countdown
Jalen and Jacoby and also get up guess
my MVP vote I would say that you will
probably take a look at I wait because
I'm white I'm taking looka done check
Wow nobody can name players go you know
him at Christmas porzingis if you ask
the average man and they're one of the
top handful of teams in the league in
the Western Conference who you got I got
a guy who's underrated nobody talks
about him being an MVP has it won an MVP
in eight years LeBron James I'm not mad
at that you can fight that he second by
the way that's it you know what and we
love a story Jalen we've already done a
Greek freak story
LeBron doing what he's doing at this age
come on it's almost splitting hairs
because LeBron James taking on the team
at school and still giving me over 25
leave the league in the system pretty
sure that was a bucket list thing and he
has regular season greatest of all time
he's trying to achieve like catch Kareem
on the scoring market he's been
outstanding and Lakers number one seed
in the West but there is a player whose
team has a better record who averages
more point averages more rebound and
just so happens to be the reigning MVP
but it's not a better story though it's
not a better story and you know what
these writers do they love a good story
here right but here's the one thing and
saying writers it's almost like saying
buying a DVD radius is that more than
writers vote now including myself
broadcast what I am a writer okay yeah
you're you're a poet to your we're okay
so the media is is voting on this okay
couple other things here I'm starting to
buy into small ball for the regular
season I mean it's it as you know and I
tell this audience all the time
basketball during the regular season is
different than basketball in the
postseason because you can be real fun
and it can work in the regular season a
seven-game series against the team that
is gearing up just to stop your style
that's what it comes down to with the
Rockets while are they're fascinating I
got to see it you know come May and June
what do you think you know Cesar's
venturing in your school in the audience
or real game that's exactly correct
there to this disease is how you perform
in the regular season versus let's me
asking you in the postseason how about
this multi media example there's a
difference between being on a show when
I hit the guide and I see your name and
or your name is on the show that means
you're the marquee ie Dan Patrick and
they're going to be people in the
industry that come on your show if they
a those five seconds I was on the
ratings went up I'm really good it is
the way different when you're
responsible for bringing it every day
and in the regular season you can do all
of the gimmicks and model I love small
ball is really unlocked Wilson much book
that's what it did you take capella off
the baseline you put Russell Westbrook
on the wing and the previous game is
called 20 points in the paint
almost like in Shaquille O'Neal so
that's really what they did is just
change the geometry of the floor but in
the postseason when the game does slow
down low tall guys always seem to get a
lot closer to the basket
be a lot more efficient lock a lot more
shots and get a chance to be more
physical so I'm going to always go with
the height and the Lakers have that and
the skill the Clippers have the
perimeter lockdown defense and all with
as long as they're healthy with
cooperatively and they're
I can allow them the height of the box
to be honest I'm on the moped so I hit
you still a puncher's chance but they're
third in our ranking orders of the West
if you could help giant one thing in the
offseason what would it be right here
that's the only thing that's going to
unlike his game um he's he's so very
athletic he's so humble and I look at
prospects and all okay but they be
successful without sports and I and I
get that from him and I appreciate it
bother me you know offensive rebounds he
was his deflection repeat he's the
ultimate teammate that just so happened
to have number one overall accolades
he's really standing by minute
left-handed and of course you wanted to
be able to make a jump shot but if he
gives his right hand he think about this
were you watching him play of all time
your favorite dunkers you litt there
right-handed they're doing in off the
left leg and or vice versa he can go do
both plus jump off both feet so I would
say of course you want them to shoot
better but if the hitter right here it's
gonna be all your favorite Kobe story my
favorite Kobe story is that Irina to do
a pilot called Damon vs. everybody and
one of the ideas that I and we in the
production team written to promote it
and to be a part of it was Kobe statue
unveiling and a part of this got your
own building would be jump shooting a
turnaround jumper and he guarding him
facing the wrong way out of homage to
his 81 point game hand him the idea he
appreciated he liked it did a script
called 81 hours and I'm pretty sure
people feel on the internet now where we
in the pond restaurant downtown and I'm
just trying to enjoy my day and all of a
sudden I'm running the Kobe Bryant at a
booth and you know instead of him just
ordering a martini he has to get 81
hours to try to try to make a mockery
out of me so I appreciated him forever
for doing that
I knew that like myself he wanted to get
into production and he wanted to do some
writing and if you notice in that skit
that really says hey what you enjoy the
time there you know I'm write him a
little bit invest in a little bit that's
not normal
with triathlete things that you say and
that's that's what made Kobe Bryant a
late great Kobe Bryant so great he was a
Renaissance man he spoke more through
the languages he's the champion he was a
leader as a family man and he's totally
going to be missed as I want to take a
doorless there's obviously to their
family and all of the families that were
affected I love it whenever it's brought
up to you that hey Kobe got 81 like it
was on you it was on the Raptors but you
say I didn't guard him the whole night
but you got the blame you guy yeah you
got blame and I'm married to Molly and
you know I got a fresh haircut all of
the time and I'm pretty weird top tiers
and bulges and clips and I got the
mirrors when I got dropped and I even
went to the dermatologist a couple of
times there of course how safe is Kobe's
81 it's extremely safe I don't know the
only way somebody to talk bad if I
decide to come out of retirement Oh get
out of here what's the most you ever had
in the game it's always great to talk to
you and thanks for joining us
tailing we appreciate it as always
that's a Jalen Rose he'll be on NBA
countdown tonight then on the jump
tomorrow in Boston before the Rockets
Celtics also contributes to get up and
be a countdown and of course his show
with Jalen and Jacoby